have gamma-MG-US recommendations to keep this stable. So gamma-MG-US is a model
clonal gamma-opathy, which is like a it's not cancer, but it can be a precursor to
multiple myeloma and other blood disorders. Similar to there's other diseases,
problems at Epidia and other diseases, myeloblastic, myeloplorific diseases that
are precursors to lymphoma precursors to leukemia precursors to multiple myeloma,
the blood disorders, the blood cancers. So how do you keep that at bay? How do you
keep that stable? Well, there is no magic way to keep any of those things stable.
You just try to clean up your diet, clean up anything that could be, you know,
it's just like any other disease process or collection of symptoms that we call
syndromes. Whatever you're having, you know, health, you want to be digging to
the reason why. Many times which you'll find in some of the core reasons why is
is gut health and inflammation. He did autoimmune diseases that you've never
knew you had. So doing some functional medicine tests can be helpful. I've said
many, many of our holistic health hours, many people will go in for a annual
physical and they'll get blood work done, but nobody ever goes over their blood
work. And they're either that or they're told everything was in normal range,
but then they look at their blood work and some things are outside of the normal
range. I have a nice little video that explains the difference between what
normal lab ranges are and functional ranges. So there's a difference between what
is considered a normal range for a lab value and what is considered a normal
functional range for a lab value. We use white blood cells as an example.
Normal lab range on a white blood cell, every lab can have a different normal range,
but typical normal lab ranges in white blood cells typically like 4.0 to maybe 11.
But functional normal functional lab ranges should be like 4.5 to maybe 7.5.
But if you're at an 8 or 8.5 in your white blood cell count, that's an elevated white
blood cell count from a functional medicine perspective. That means quite possibly
you're dealing with either a chronic or acute infection that is not being diagnosed.
Now, if a person has constant lab values that are outside of that functional range,
we'll continue to use white blood cell count as an example. Let's say they,
well, the last four labs they did over the last two years, they had white blood
cell counts in the 8s or 9s or something. Well, that's indicative of maybe a
chronic viral infection or something like that that has never been addressed. Well,
what's the problem with the chronic viral infection? If I don't have any symptoms from it,
well, you could have inflammation from it. You have chronic inflammation,
just this chronic low grade or medium grade inflammation can cause all sorts of
disuses in our body can affect how our white blood cells are producing,
giving it a disease named like this can affect also the list is endless.
So going to a functional medicine doctor, getting some labs done,
even simple labs that you'd get at a normal physical,
a CBC and a complete metabolic panel put under the scrutiny of functional
medicine perspectives and lab values could give you so very big clues on what
could else could be going on that you may want to further investigate.
For instance, let's use white blood cell count again. So let's say the white blood cell
is elevated and lymphocytes are elevated giving you clues that you could have a
chronic viral infection. Well, is that possibly causing something else?
So maybe do an antibody test and you see that this person has self-antibodies
to whatever came up positive. Then you do, well, what else is causing
inflammation this body that is causing self-antibodies. You do a biochemical
screen or you do a food antibody test so you could come up with all sorts of
information. And then you could better treat the patient, better know what could
be a cause of a problem with the patient and direct care in that way.
It's in just getting my struggle with what the practice of medicine has become
quite often. It's practice of functional medicine has become is labs being
done just to achieve a diagnosis instead of labs being done to find now a
course of action to help that person come back to normality or to the best
level of help that they have ability to come to. So our labs in tests are not
to be done just so we can. Oh, you have, you know, an increase in plasma cells.
So we're going to give you this disease name. So we're going to watch it and
we'll finally do something once it turns into multiple myeloma. To me, that's
that's not permitted to medicine. All you did is come up with a diagnosis,
put a name on it and again, their hands are tied to medical perspective.
They're going to use type some sort of medicine is probably going to be a
drug, which may alter the lab, but it's not actually fixing the patient,
but digging into why that is the case. So how would I keep a pre cancerous
condition at bay? I would dig into why. So I would get into some functional
medicine tests. Maybe antibody tests, maybe even start by looking deeper
through a functional medicine perspective of the CBC and complete metabolic
panel that you probably had done on a regular basis and start looking for
clues and give us direction on what other tests should be the next course of
action to get to some core things. The help with that, you could certainly
contact our office through our website cutters clinic. You could schedule a case
review with me through our self-schedule page. And, you know, I don't, I'm pretty sure
I don't have any blog posts on this particular condition, but you can find all sorts of
blog posts about cancer that might be helpful and different possible causes of
cancer that may be to be helpful because things that cause pre cancerous
conditions can be followed to those same categories.